今天我们继续来讲《红楼梦》。前一天我解读了一些红楼梦里,比如萤春、西春,还有林红雨身上的一些疑问,以此来验证红楼梦是经过山改的。其实红楼梦里的山改痕迹有些非常明显,有些就比较隐会。像前几天写的萤春、西春,还有林红雨这些的话,就是比较隐会的。我们需要从红楼梦里找出各种论具来进行。
今天我们从红楼梦里挑了五个,非常非常明显的例子,我们来看今天第1个问题,是林代域探病内容的确实,具体的张回是第35回。
然后这是第35回墨尾,这里的前前就是第33回甲宝域被甲证给打了,然后35回一直在养病,这是第35回墨尾。墨尾提到行福人来给甲宝域送了一些果子,然后又提到,然后甲宝域就让秋文把果子送去给林姑娘,也就是林代域。
秋文刚要走的时候,只听待域在院内说话,保育忙脚快请,然后她来了一句要知端地且听下回分解,也就是说林代域来给甲宝域探病的内容应该在第36回开篇要讲,但是我们打开第36回,这就是第36回开篇。
完全没有写到林代域来到一红远之后跟甲宝域收了哪些话,做了哪些事。她直接说,话说甲母字王夫任处回来,见宝域一日好事一日,心中自事欢喜。
也就是说林代域探病甲宝域,然后中间发生的那些事情全部都没有了。这个这部分内容的确实我个人觉得真的是非常的遗憾,因为第34回的时候甲宝域让秦文给林代域送了两块救怕。
林代域看见这两块救怕,她就理解了甲宝域对自己的心意,也就是说他们两个人的感情应该会通过这件事情有一个进一步的提升。
所以我个人真的是非常好奇,他们两个人下一次在见面的时候,他们会说什么话。
因为这个非常考验作者的写作功底,就是两个人都清楚了彼此的心意之后,他们两会怎么相处,他们的眼神他们怎么说话。
但是这部分内容确实残缺了,就是一点都没有了。
然后我们顺便说一下第36回开篇这句话,话说甲母自王夫认出回来见宝域一日好事一日,心中自事欢喜。
我在之前的视频里曾经解读过,这句话其实也是错误的,他把甲宝域受伤给高混了。
他说话说甲母自王夫认出回来,是因为他以为甲宝域在王夫认的住处养伤,其实他这句话对应的是红罗梦的第25回,也魔法书嫂风无鬼。
内议回离甲宝域重演了之后,他被搬到了王夫认的住处,然后一直养病养了33天才回来。
但是第三是三回甲宝域被甲证吃他之后,他并没有带在王夫人的住处,原住理写的很清楚就是甲母直接派人就把他送回一红远了。
所以甲母不可能去王夫人的住处,探望甲宝域,这应该是坐着写混了,因为坐着可能是对红罗梦时代是太熟悉了。
所以他因为熟悉,他反而把两个两次伤比给高混了。
这是第一处非常明显的错误,然后第二处明显的错误就是第40回的牙排令,风波的缺失。
这是第40回的墨尾,也就是使泰军两业大官员中最后的金冤养三宣牙排令,
最后一位醒酒令的人是刘老老,也就是这一段,大火烧了猫猫从一个罗伯一头蒜就这一段。
然后说完之后这段墨尾,众人大笑之后,草血已经写了一句,只听外面乱长长的不知合适,且听下回分解。
这跟第35回36回墨尾开篇的段例是一样的,我们再打开第30,再打开第41回看一下。
大家看第41回开篇的时候,再一次出现了锻炼。
外面乱长的到底发生了什么事,不知道,他直接把这段内容给掐掉,然后继续续上刘老老的那个花儿落了接个大窝罐,继续接刘老老的牙排令,而把外面发生了什么事情彻底给删掉了。
至于草血庭为什么会这么做,以我站在个人创作的角度来说的话,我觉得草血庭可能是为了避免重复。
因为第39回刘老老二进中国府的时候,他给家母等人讲那个相间的故事,当中呢,中国府就发生了一次火灾。
当时也说外面乱长的有人说,外面走水了,大家快去看。
那个时候已经出现了一次,外面乱长了,然后大家出去看了情节,然后如果这里再写一次的话可能会显得重复。
我个人猜测草血庭可能是基于这个考虑,然后把这一段的牙排令风波弄出一个风波这一段给删掉,避免跟第39回有重复。
当然了,这只是我个人的一个猜测不一定完全准确,大家可以参考一下,但不要当作是正确答案,可以自己去想一想。
然后我们再来说第3个问题,就是家母跟学宝拆的生日存疑的问题。
原住第62回的时候曾经提到过家母的生日,就是这一段是碳春说的。
碳春说,大年初一是大姐姐的生日,大姐姐就是原春是大年初一生日,然后他又说过了登杰就是老太太和宝姐姐,他们娘儿两个遇得巧。
按照碳春的说法,家母跟学宝才是同一天生日,但是这个内容到后面就完全不对了,我们看第71回的时候,就是这一段。
第71回介绍家母的生日的时候说的非常的清楚,说8月初三日,乃家母八循之庆。
而且写的非常详细,包括这些验会怎么设置,看是从7月28日开始到8月初,8月初五,然后28日请哪些人,29日请哪些人,然后30日是哪些人,然后初一是假设的家艳,初二是假证的家艳,初三日是假真假脸,然后这些写的非常详细。
所以家母是8月初三日生日,但是为什么碳春这里又说老太太和宝姐姐是同一天生日,而且是过了登杰,也就是言消解。
要把这个问题说清楚的话,我们就不得不再翻开第22回,也就是学宝才生日的那一回。
那一回开篇鳳姐就说了,21是学妹妹的生日,对吧,所以学宝猜是争月21生日,人家碳春说的没错,学宝猜确实是登杰过后就是宝猜的生日,登杰是争月15,学宝猜是争月21,两个确实是连在一起的。
但是家母的生日跟学宝猜很明显就不是同一天,我们可以来试着理解分析一下,就以第22回为例,如果家母跟学宝猜是同一天生日的话,学宝猜的生日即是家母的生日。
那么,学宝猜就算他是荣国府的客人,家母只要能给他过生日,那么家母这样的长辈,学一妈,学宝猜鳳姐这些人他们不可能不提今天也是家母的生日。
所以说家母的生日在这里的话,一定会有所体现,可是我们看第22回内容的时候,所有人都把家母的生日给忘掉了,大家都不知道今天是家母的生日。
也就是说第22回跟第71回家母的生日是合在一起的,家母的生日确实是8月初三,学宝猜的生日是争月21,所以第22回学宝猜生日的时候,没人会觉得对不起家母,因为家母的生日根本就不是争月21,而是8月初三。
至于第62回,碳春把老太太跟宝姐姐的生日放在同一天,我觉得应该是早稿跟金稿的一个问题,就是第62回的内容应该是早稿,后来就把两个人的老太太跟宝姐姐可能一开始真的是同一天生日,然后后来改成了家母是8月初三。
然后第62回的内容没有进行修正就导致出现了这样的问题,其实如果曹雪琴把这里改一下,就是第62回,她说过了灯节就是宝姐姐的生日,对吧,她只要这里一改,不要把老太太放进去,这么一改的话,第22第62第71,三个张回的内容就全都通了。
然后我们再来讲第四个内容,就是元非送灯迷的时间存议问题,具体参考的张节还是要参考第22回,第22回存在一个非常大的问题就是时空缘导的问题。
第22回一共讲了两件事,第一件事就是学宝财争议21过生日,第二件事就是智灯迷夹正被称语,也就是争月15,元非从宫里送来了灯迷夹府的这些子妹们就一起去猜。
这里就存在一个问题就是时间她前后颠导了,因为都说了人家宝财是争月21生日,可是她先写的是宝财的生日,宝财生日过去之后她才写元非给容国府这边送灯迷。
我一开始还在找补,就是从学经为什么写反了,宝财的生日,争月21都已经过了,怎么突然又到了争月15元消解,然后她送来这个灯迷,我还想是不是这个灯迷言后了,但我后来发现应该不是,因为我们在看第22回漠尾,
也就是治灯迷夹正被称语,夹正猜灯迷,猜完灯迷之后她觉得这些灯迷非常的不详,然后她心里就沉思了一句,她说,
她说,娘娘所做暴族此乃一小儿散之物,营村所做算牌是打动蓝荣麻,探村所做风整耐飘飘浮荡之物,西村所做海灯,一发轻尽孤独,今乃上元家结,如何接做此不相之物为戏野。
她这里专门提到说,金乃元,金乃上元家结,也就是说,今天就是争月15,所以说第22回的时间确实是写错了,至于她为什么会写错我现在还不知道原因,
因为这个问题实在是太明显了,先是争月15,应该先写原非的灯迷在写保采的生日采对,她为什么把两个翻过来了,这是我现在还是有点想不通的。
大家如果对这个问题有什么见解的话,也可以一起去探讨一下,然后我们再来看最后一个问题就是今天的第五个问题就是,假保育呼引呼现的问题。
具体的张回是第45回,也就是大家非常熟悉的,就是李丸带着种子妹来问王西奉所要时射的设备那一回。
那一回开篇,我们来看她写的是,话说奉击正府序平而呼见种子妹进来。
这里说种子妹进来,显然假保育不在里面,包括后来我们看后面,就是,包括后来,李丸成功所要到了设备之后,奉击她已经猜到了,
种子妹来问自己要前是假保育总用他们过来的,于是奉击就说了一句,她说这些事在没两个人都是保育生出来的。
如果假保育在现场的话,奉击一定会纠住假保育问话,可是我们看这个整体设置里,假保育完全没有出场,奉击说起保育来也是李丸在回话。
这里面显然假保育不在了,可是紧接着,李丸准备走的时候,赖默默来了。
赖默默来是因为她的孙子赖上荣,捐了一个官职,马上就要走了,然后请荣国府这边的主子们到自己家里去做课。
也就是第四十期回,待霸王调情遭苦打那一回,柳香脸削盘都去赖家吃血,然后削盘对柳香脸有一些意思,然后柳香脸就把她骗了地里打了一段那一段。
然后这一段赖默默因为是假蒙那一代的人,所以她挺有体面的。
她在跟众人聊天之后,她也提到了假保育,我们看,我们来看这一段。
她也提到了假保育,而且这时候假保育已经在现场了,我们来看这一段。
大家看这一段,她写说赖默默应有指的保育说不怕你嫌我,如今老爷不过这么管你一管,老太太户在头里,当日老爷小时候哀你爷爷的打谁没看见的。
赖默默能指着保育说话,显然假保育是在现场的。
可是她既然在现场为什么前文里面,把假保育的所有信息全都引掉了。
所以一开始我还在想,开篇提到说,忽见众子媒进来,是不是假保育也在这个众子媒里面。
但是后来我对默默默理假保育跟众子媒同时出场,这种情境进行了一个减所发现,情况并不是这样的。
就是如果假保育跟众子媒一起出场的话,草血情会把假保育单独拆出来,比如她会说保育与众子媒来了。
她不会说众子媒,然后又默认假保育就在这个众子媒里面,这种情况是没有发生过的。
所以包括我们刚才说的,王西方察觉到是假保育,带着众姐妹过来的,送用他们过来的,她就抱怨了假保育几句。
如果假保育在现场,凤姐一定会对着保育说话,可是她没有,假保育也没有接任何话,反倒是理完过来接话。
所以这个问题也是我有点想不通的,就是假保育到底再不在现场,包括王西方在现场点破假保育,所有大家能问她有钱的时候假保育始终没有站出来。
反倒是后来,赖摩摩教训假保育的时候,她说指着保育,但是保育还是没有一句话。
这个问题我个人也还在思考,大家也可以一起思考一下。
那这就是今天视频的全部内容了,我们下个视频再见。